how do nuclear weapons change the
calculus of offensive realism because of
mutually assur destruction I mean it's
not just military might it's just so
destructive that you basically can't use
nuclear
weapons unless you want complete
destruction there's no question that the
presence of nuclear weapons makes it
much less likely I'm choosing my words
carefully much less likely that a great
power would aggress against another
great power it doesn't take that
possibility off the table but it makes
it much less likely because of the
reasons that you
articulated uh but with regard to
nuclear
use it's an interesting question how you
think about nuclear use in a mad world I
mean your point that we're in a mad
world
is that's mad Capital mad as well as mad
small letters but let's stick to the
capital letters we're in a world of
mutual assured destruction um there's no
question that in that
World um it's uh unlikely that nuclear
weapons would be used but the way you
use nuclear weapons in that world is you
use them uh for manipulation to risk
purposes demonstration of fact you you
put both sides out on the slippery slope
now what exactly am I saying here let me
talk about NATO Doctrine during the Cold
War we lived in a Mad World United
States and Soviet Union or The wara Pact
in NATO both had an assured destruction
capability so you had mutual assured
destruction if the Warsaw Pact were to
invade Western Europe and here we're
talking about West
Germany uh and NATO was losing the war
we said that we would use nuclear
weapons how would we use nuclear weapons
given that we were in a Mad World the
argument was that we would use a handful
of nuclear weapons Against The warsa
Pact not through not necessarily against
their military forces could be in a
remote area we would use a small number
of nuclear weapons mhm to signal to the
Soviets that we were deadly serious
about putting an end to their
offensive uh and that we were throwing
both sides out on the slippery slope to
Oblivion in other words we were
manipulating risk and the last clear
chance to avoid Armageddon rested with
them and then we would tell them that if
you retaliated with a handful of nuclear
weapons and you didn't cease your
offensive against West Germany
we would launch a small another nuclear
attack we would uh explode a handful
more of nuclear weapons all for the
purposes of showing you our resolve
right so this is the manipulation of
risk strategy and a lot of the language
I just used in describing it to you is
language that Thomas shelling invented
right now fast forward to the present if
Russia were you losing in Ukraine that's
the one scenario I think where Russia
would have used nuclear weapons and the
question is how would Russia have used
nuclear weapons again we're assuming
that the Russians are losing to the
ukrainians I believe they would have
pursued a manipulation of risk strategy
they would have used four5 30 or4 who
knows nuclear weapons maybe just one in
a rural area that kills very few people
yes exactly and basically
that would spook everybody the American
just the mushroom cloud yeah the it it's
because of the threat of escalation
right again you your point is we're in a
mad world I accept that and if you have
limited nuclear use right we understand
hardly anything about nuclear escalation
because thank goodness we've never had a
nuclear war so once you throw both sides
out on the slippery slope even if you
only use one nuclear weapon in your
scenario you don't know what the
escalation Dynamics look like so
everybody has a powerful incentive to
put an end to the conflict right away I
might add to you that there were people
who believed that we would not even
initiate a manipulation of risk strategy
in Europe if we were losing to the warsa
PCT during the Cold War both Henry
Kissinger and Robert mcnemar said after
leaving office that they would not have
done it they would have not initiated
nuclear use even limited nuclear use
that's what we're talking about here
they would rather be red than dead right
that was the argument too risky too
risky that's exactly right but if they
had used one nuclear weapon in your
story or three or four in my story
everybody would have said oh my God
we've got to shut this one down
immediately I only tell you this story
or lay out this scenario be as an answer
to your question of how you use nuclear
weapons in a mad world and this is the
answer I this is all very terrifying uh
perhaps in part it's terrifying to me
because I can see in the 21st
century China
Russia Israel United States using a
nuclear weapon in this
way blowing it up somewhere in the
middle of nowhere that kills maybe
nobody but I'm terrified of seeing the
mushroom cloud and not
knowing what you know given social media
given how fast news
travels what the escalation looks like
there just you know in in in a in a
matter of minutes how the news travels
and how the the leaders react it's
terrifying that this this little
demonstration of power um the Ripple
effects of it in a matter of minutes
seconds what that leads to because it's
like it's human emotions it's like you
you see the landscape of human emotions
the leaders and the populace and and the
way news are reported and then the
landscape of risk as you mentioned
shifting like the world's most int
intense nonlinear dynamical
system and it it it's just terrifying
because the the the entirety of human
civilizations hangs in the balance there
and it's like like
this like hundreds of millions of people
could be dead let's just talk about this
in the context of the Ukraine war
um if uh if the Russians were losing as
I said before which is not the case
anymore but in 20 22 it it did look like
that um if the Russians are losing and
they turn to nuclear
weapons the question is how do they use
them and they would use them in
Ukraine and because Ukraine has no
nuclear weapons of its own Ukraine
cannot retaliate it's not a mutual
assured destruction world it's a case
where one side has nuclear weapons and
the other doesn't
that means that the Russians are likely
to think that they can get away with
using nuclear weapons in ways that would
not be the case if they were attacking
NATO and therefore it makes nuclear use
more likely okay that's point one point
two is let's assume that the Russians
use two or three nuclear weapons in a
remote area sweating by the way just
just as a commentary the question
terrifying yeah the question then is
what does the West do now macron has
said and Biden has also I think
implicitly made this clear we would not
retaliate with nuclear weapons if the
Russians were to attack with a handful
of nuclear weapons in Western
Ukraine but then the question is what
would we do and if you listen to David
Petraeus what David Petraeus says is
that we should attack the Russian naval
Assets in the black
say and attack Russian forces in
Ukraine well once you do that you have a
great power of War you have NATO versus
Russia which is another way of saying
you have the United States versus Russia
we're now in a great power War they have
nuclear weapons we have nuclear weapons
they've used nuclear weapons what is the
happy ending here and just to take it a
step further and go back to our earlier
discussion about moving NATO up to
Russia's borders the point I made which
you surely agree with is that the
Russians are very fearful when they see
NATO coming up to their border well
here's a case where not only is NATO
come up to their border but they're in a
war with NATO right on their
border what are the escalation Dynamics
look like there you know what the answer
is who knows that's should scare the
living but Jesus out of you right and
some of it could be like you mentioned
unintended there could be unintended
consequences there could be a Russian
missile misses and hits
Poland these kinds of things that just
escalate misunderstandings
miscommunications even a I mean nuclear
weapon could be boy it could have been
planned to go location X and it went to
a location y that ended up actually
killing a very large number of people I
mean
uh
just that the the escalation that
happens there just happens in in a
matter of minutes and the only way to
stop that is communication between
leaders and that to me is a big argument
for ongoing communication you know
this's a story that during the Cuban
Missile Crisis U Kennedy put out the
word uh no
aircraft uh under any circumstances or
to penetrate Soviet airspace yeah yeah
and he then found out a few days later
that uh some guy hadn't gotten the
message and had penetrated in an
aircraft deep into Soviet airspace yeah
and uh this supports your basic point
that you know uh bad things happen and
uh and again the overarching point here
is we've never done this before
thankfully therefore we don't have a lot
of experience as to how it plays itself
out it it's really a theoretical
Enterprise because there's no empirical
basis for talking about
escalation uh you know in a nuclear
crisis and that of course is a wonderful
thing well and in general the uh the
human species as a whole is a is a
oneoff is a theoretical Enterprise the
survival of the human species you know
we've seen Empires rise and fall but we
haven't seen the human species rise and
fall so far it's been rising but uh it's
not obvious that it doesn't end in fact
I think about aliens a lot and the fact
that we don't see aliens makes me
suspect it's not so easy to survive in
this complicated world of
ours